a experiente sim tá trabalhando com eles
mudou bastante coisa na minha visão de
mundo que eu acreditava então as pessoas
foi um processo e criar integração junto
com eles se recuperar e tentar passar
por tudo que nós passamos na vida com os
vencedores não é tão fácil quanto antes
parece às vezes não
a gente é sua amante e pra adi diga que
está a gente quer viver a gente quer me
ver feliz
liberdade
falar de um conceito pelo seu contrário
prisão eu vim aqui falar de cárcere
meu nome é rafael guimarães eu tenho uma
empresa e nessa empresa há 10 anos atrás
quando eu abrir eu criei um produto que
ela veio antes da empresa naturalmente
né primeiro nasceu em mim que é um
produto de moda conceitual com alcance
de vanguarda e de uma tendência bem
forte de uma moda contemporânea mas
feito com elementos rudimentares que são
agulhas e linhas de forma artesanal e
pra fazer esse produto eu não tinha uma
mão de obra que eu pudesse contratar de
maneira profissional porque é a maioria
dessa cultura de tricô e crochê
ela fica reservada às prendas domésticas
são nossas avós nossas tias as senhoras
que já tem um outro conceito de vida que
o faziam como hobby
então eu comecei a ter vários problemas
na hora que eu ia buscar uma mercadoria
a não conseguir entregar a tempo porque
o meu fogão explodiu o meu neto ficou
doente o meu marido se hospitalizou
enfim coisas do dia a dia de uma senhora
dona de casa que é quem guarda essa
riqueza do feito à mão no nosso país na
nossa cultura no brasil e aí é eu falei
como eu vou organizar uma mão de obra
que esteja disponível que tenha tempo
para aprender e se esse ofício e que
esteja reunida nem porque o produto
artesanal ele é como uma caligrafia por
exemplo você pode dar a mesma palavra na
mesma folha de papel com a mesma caneta
que o meu vai ser completamente
diferente do seu
na estética e o produto manual é assim
também a mesma agulha o mesmo fio a
mesma receita de ponto
o meu ponto nunca será igual ao ponto da
minha colega então quanto meio quanto
mais concentrada e reunida tiver tiverem
esses artesãos mais fácil a gente
ajustar a questão de tamanho e todas as
exigências né de moda para o mercado
externo e por um produto que tenha uma
embora artesanal ele tenha uma sequência
industrial de uma mínima repetição é e
aí com esse dilema em mãos é eu falei
onde eu vou buscar uma mão de obra que
esteja concentrada e que tenha tempo pra
aprender o ofício e fazê lo de forma
profissional e aí dentro todos os grupos
de pessoas que eu pensei o que mais me
emocionou foi o desafio de entrar numa
penitenciária e oferecer esse serviço
para quem está excluído da sociedade
quando a gente fala de exclusão da
sociedade a gente pensa na maneira como
a gente tem aí caminhado na nossa
concepção social que é muito triste que
tenha um abismo social muito grande de
divisão de riquezas
a gente não pensa no pequeno no
sentenciado a gente pensa nas pessoas
que estão nas periferias a gente pensa
nesse tipo de exclusão mas a exclusão de
um marginal é uma exclusão muito
perversa perversa porque porque a gente
exclui a gente apaga do nosso convívio a
gente retira da nossa sociedade ea gente
esquece que a pena por si só não
ressocializa ninguém o que ressocialize
é dar a esse indivíduo a dignidade de
refazer a sua vida e se a gente faz a
nossa vida através das nossas escolhas
de afeto e através das nossas escolhas
profissionais
o indivíduo marginal que está
marginalizado ele precisa ter acesso aos
seus afetos à sua família e precisa ter
acesso à ferramenta de trabalho a
oportunidade e infelizmente a gente não
cria essa oportunidade
a gente simplesmente os e grega o exclui
e não pensa que ali ele precisa ter a
oportunidade de trabalho e ele precisa
ter o apoio da família ea educação à
escolarização que muitas vezes na rua na
sociedade
ele não teve né e aí fui para dentro de
uma penitenciária
fui entender esse conceito de cárcere
teve grande dificuldade é claro porque
não é simples você entrar numa unidade
prisional com agulha com tesoura com uma
ideia sendo uma mulher né
e com uma idéia de um produto de moda de
design que está completamente distante
das referências de design que essas
pessoas conviveram que a maioria dessas
pessoas é a gente está generalizando é
conviver um grande
a maior parte de suas vidas enquanto
estavam fora do cárcere que geralmente é
um período muito curto esse tempo de
vida antes do carteiro porque a nossa
população carcerária é muito jovem então
o menino já está no crime desde a
adolescência muitas vezes desde a
infância ele faz 18 anos e ele entra por
sistema né
então são meninos são adultos muitos
jovens que estão lá dentro
e nesse sentido eu consegui vencer tudo
o que eu precisava em termos de
credibilidade e de confiança do estado e
da população carcerária para conseguir
montar uma oficina de produção da
empresa dentro da penitenciária
professor ariosvaldo campos pires em
juiz de fora
na época contei com um apoio muito
grande da diretoria da penitenciária que
se colocava com muita boa vontade pra
que aquela é aquela oficina pioneiro
tivesse sucesso a ele e nós tivemos nós
tivemos casos é sensacionais é de
pessoas que realmente se recuperaram
eu comecei inicialmente trabalhando com
homens na área osvaldo homens que
ensinar que aprenderam a fazer tricô e
crochê e que hoje me fazer tricô e
crochê talvez melhor que a minha avó que
foi quem me ensinou quando eu tinha
cinco anos de idade e trouxe toda essa
herança do feito à mão de minas gerais
para uma moda contemporânea né
então hoje o que a gente tem de produção
dentro de unidades prisionais a gente
mostra isso com muito orgulho para o
mundo inteiro
e aí vamos falar de liberdade e vamos
falar da liberdade de uma pessoa poder
refazer a sua vida
da liberdade de uma pessoa que está
presa criar dela ter uma liberdade que
não é mais física porque ela tem em
volta dela algemas muros e grades e todo
um sistema de totalização então ela não
tem direito a acordar e vesti azul
ela tem que acordar e vestir vermelho ou
vestir laranja ou vestir a cor que seja
do seu estado né ela não tem a liberdade
de escolher o que ela vai começar ela tá
com vontade de comer uma coisa diferente
daquilo que é servido ela não tenha
liberdade de poder ir e se e ter algum
prazer de sua escolha
ela não tem a liberdade de trocar o
canal da televisão ela não tenha
liberdade tudo dela é é absolutamente é
vigiado e punido
e aí nós damos a essa pessoa a liberdade
de criar a liberdade de trabalhar a
liberdade de sonhar novamente com a
liberdade
e aí o que se tornou mais é interessante
do ponto de vista do entendimento de
como a gente leva a nossa vida com o
nosso direito à liberdade é que lá
dentro eles não têm liberdade mas eles
têm tempo aqui fora a gente tem
liberdade e não tem tempo e que eles
passaram a fazer para ganhar liberdade e
me vender o tempo deles
esse trabalho é remunerado a cada três
dias trabalhados eles têm um dia de
remissão de pena e se esse trabalho é
muito valorizado né então não existe
preconceito dentro do sistema foram eles
que eu tenho uma brincadeira lá que
quando eles começaram os outros
sentenciados que estavam fora do projeto
falava lá vão as costureiras né porque
como vocês podem imaginar é uma
população extremamente machista e e aí
comecei a trabalhar dança com eles aí
começará lavam as bailarinas
até que um dia um muito grande muito
alto e muito forte e colocou a mão nas
cadeiras e falou lá vão as ricas porque
porque eles têm salário e quem tem
salário tenham
economia e quem tem salário tem uma
certa liberdade né
e aí dentro dessa história eles se
tornaram pessoas me vendendo o seu tempo
e eu devolvendo a eles a liberdade
porque eu não né halep que a lei de
execuções penais que garante o trabalho
sentenciado porque porque como eles
trabalham três dias e tem um dia de
remissão de pena então significa que
eles vão passar menos tempo no cárcere
ao longo de sua pena que eles vão abater
um terço da pena trabalhando é e aí a
sociedade me pergunta muito nossa mais a
pessoa que cometeu um crime hediondo ela
tem que está em já o lado encarcerada e
sofrendo muito
eu contesto eu acho que qualquer pessoa
precisa de afeto qualquer pessoa precisa
de amor
qualquer pessoa precisa de uma segunda
chance então com a minha relação com
eles passa pelo amor sim minha relação
com eles passa pelo olho no olho e pela
festa porque o perdão não quer saber eu
não quero perguntar que crime eles
cometeram o crime fica do lado de fora
eles estão pagando isso acertando suas
contas com a justiça
ali pra mim eu deixo o crime de fora e
entra o trabalhador e entre o homem e
entra um sujeito que quer recomeçar a
sua vida e eu posso dizer a todos vocês
eles recomendam tem uma história linda
de um sentenciado que saiu para o regime
semiaberto me procurou imediatamente
porque eu deixo o do meu telefone ou
endereço é enem2010 me dá uma
oportunidade
na época eu abri uma vaga pra ele no meu
escritório que o a parte burocrática
obviamente não fica nossa ana na
penitenciária e ali ele foi aprendendo
tudo que ele pode aprender ele entrou
ele fez um curso na universidade federal
de juiz de fora de capacitação
profissional na área de administração
ele havia sido roubado por tráfico e de
desculpa ele havia sido preso por
tráfico de drogas e roubo ness o tráfico
ele arrasta muitos outros crimes junto
com ele e ali ele estava tendo acesso ao
meu financeiro ele estava tendo acesso a
todos os votos de confiança
eu poderia dar a ele quando o escritório
por questões pessoais minhas de vida me
mudei de juiz de fora o escritório saiu
de juiz de fora a minha maior
preocupação era se ele conseguiria se
encaixar novamente com os antecedentes
criminais que ele tinha no mercado de
trabalho e um dia posso dizer mais feliz
da minha vida
acho que eu até me emociona sempre
pensando é eu tenho filhos maravilhosos
até um marido maravilhoso tem vários
momentos felizes e muito felizes da
minha vida mas eu vou dizer a vocês o
dia que o sérgio tavares me ligou
dizendo que ele quer um homem que foi um
traficante que tinha casa que tinha
sítio que tinha carro zero estava feliz
sendo cobrador de ônibus
eu não sei dizer a vocês o símbolo que
isso tem para mim é tão magnífico é tão
lindo que é a liberdade de sonhar
a liberdade de recomeçar com muita
humildade com muita simplicidade ea
liberdade de reencarnar na mesma vida a
gente tem o direito a transformação
a gente precisa da transformação viver e
se transformar e o projeto flor de lótus
é um projeto que busca no ser humano que
ele se transforme em para o bem porque é
uma coisa que eu vou usar pra finalizar
essa minha breve fala com vocês é que a
flor de lótus ela nasce na lama e
ninguém acredita que da linha daquele
ambiente tão inóspito tanto preconceito
possam sair jóias preciosas o ser humano
merece a segunda chance e o projeto flor
de lótus está aqui pra convidar vários
empresários a criarem coragem força
perseverança para a gente fazer essa
sustentabilidade em recursos humanos
porque muitos se dirige sustentabilidade
recursos materiais né
a gente realmente tem é uma infinidade
de possibilidades de reaproveitar o que
está descartado
principalmente com criatividade mas
reaproveitar uma pessoa que está
descartada
nada é a sustentabilidade recursos
humanos que eu convido todos os
empresários a virem nesse caminho que é
um caminho de recompensa e é um caminho
de luz
muito obrigada